welcome to shutterstock headquarters
home of one of the world's largest
digital stock photo libraries located on
the 20th and 21st floors of the Empire
State Building Shutterstock brings a
startup vibe to an old-school building
this is the Alice in Wonderland room
are you kidding me its office has free
food a yoga studio massage rooms a
secret library and two unbelievable game
rooms surf like such an intense place we
get so much done here but you like that
fun too Jon Oringer started Shutterstock
11 years ago from his Manhattan
apartment
he took the company public in 2012 and
is known as the first billionaire to
come out of New York City's growing tech
scene what made you decide to stay in
New York City New York is a business
center of the world and by being here it
allows us to interact pretty often with
the biggest media agencies in the world
that's important to us 300 employees
work and shutter stocks new headquarters
but remote employees have a presence in
the new office too
this is actually called I Brian this
belongs to a remote employee
he's inside of here somewhere it's
eating the computer you can control this
from where he is and work with people in
the office shutterstock steams voted on
conference room names furniture and even
food choices but big data determine the
office layout we look back on all of our
calendars and found out that conference
rooms were used by two to five people so
we decided to create lots of smaller
ones to accommodate that building this
office is just a snapshot of a much
bigger picture for shutterstock we're
always looking for what we can do in the
future what we can build next